each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
you
welcome back I know that you had a great
time at the reception party banquet last
night because I was there and saw
everybody having fun now I didn't lose
my voice because of that I haven't even
started partying it as an infection i
have some there's an infection i had
from last week we have a great day full
of programs riding with Professor money
columns keynote starting right after
this I wanted to point you to the
research showcase that happens right
after monica's talk and you know as I
said there are these ads that talks to
talks about the different booths that
are there in the showcase there are 47
demo boots so you'll have a lot of time
I think it starts from nine whatever and
then goes and no 10 whatever it goes on
till one o'clock so use the time lunch
starts at eleven forty-five so you get
your times and then continue you know
with the research okay still have plenty
of places there to sit down and eat we
want you to check out all the different
booths that are in the research showcase
talk to the people that are demoing I
don't want to draw your attention again
to the academic services that I
mentioned yesterday this is actually
beyond just a demo set of services that
we offering please go to that booth and
give us feedback in particular research
news com as a website that's life now
now don't be looking at it now because
from santa monica is going to talk and
if I catch you doing it during his talk
you know what happens so but do look at
it go to the boots have a great day I'll
see you back in late in the afternoon
you know when I come back to the pitas
closing keynote thank you hi welcome I'm
really glad to see you all here I'm one
of the co-chairs I'm Catherine McKinley
and it's truly my pleasure to introduce
monocle am today keeping with our theme
she has her PhD from CMU but for a long
time she's been a professor at Stanford
and she directs the mobi social lab
there and Monica's research career
started in compilers where she did
foundational research on software
pipelining data locality in perelson
this influence the field greatly and
influence
I work in particular and I also took
practical advice for Monica when I met
her early in my career if you haven't
missed an airplane you're spending too
much time in airports much to my
husband's distress and um Monica's group
has produced a compiler called sweet
infrastructure that many other academics
probably many in this room have used to
further their research also your
students are learning from her her book
the compiler principle techniques and
tools the second edition of the dragon
book that she's a co-author on she's
received a Norman umber of best paper
and test of time awards and she's an ACM
fellow in 2012 Monica and her students
started Moby social and the goal of her
company is to create an OpenSocial
Internet where users can share anything
while loaning their data and that's what
she's going to talk to us about today
please join me in welcoming Monica all
right good morning so um the title of
the talk is a revolution against Big
Brother social networks what am I
talking about um how many people here
are on Facebook okay how many people are
not on Facebook well that's a lot of
people not on Facebook relative to the
general audience there for those of you
who are on facebook how many of you have
read the Terms of Service and you are
still on facebook okay so I thought that
it would be useful if we week the terms
of service together right because it is
very interesting because the first thing
you read in the Terms of Service and
says you own your data so what am i
complaining about very very simple but
then it has many many more sentences
after that so what does the next
sentence a the next sentence says you
grant us a non-exclusive transferable
sub-licensable royalty free worldwide
license taste any IP
content that you post they could have
said it in three little words so do we
right but that's what they have to put
down but in case you don't understand
what this means they spell it out they
said look you permit a fitness or other
entity to pay us to display your name in
a profile picture with your content or
information without any compensation to
you so they can make an ad out of your
picture and your name and put it
anywhere they want the billboard on the
one on the freeway and whatever and just
in case you are still not understanding
it says you understand that we may not
always identify paid services and
communications as such it means that
they can say that you like they let you
know that you like certain things and
your friends didn't even know that you
are not staying at yourself and I
thought that was pretty scary and I
think that this is I'm I feel like it's
a little bit of an insult in a sense to
go this far with our personal data that
we share with using Facebook and this
kind of reminds me of this picture okay
I mean back in the good old days there
are operators intercepting potentially
being able to intercept every single
call and here we have an environment
where they promised they will intercept
all our cloth okay and then of course
they monetize it and so forth including
selling ads using our names without
letting us know about it so if you think
that this is kind of sad that we're
going back to those days where we have
operators you have not seen its that's
not where we stop so look at what's
happening in China in China there is a
messaging called reach out how many
people know about we chat alright so
some of you don't let me tell you a
little bit about it it's a messaging app
but on this messaging app they were able
to roll out many many businesses games
taxi PTP payment p2p commerce they now
have their own Bank they have created
their own operating
system it's called a tense 10 operating
system and they want to power up the
Internet of Things and this is a closed
Network by that what do I mean he's like
if you want to so what I heard is that
if you are a large game company if you
want to distribute this game with we
chat you just have to give them
eighty-five percent of your revenues
okay so this is a social network that
you can use to cover you know to roll
out many businesses but it's mainly a
closed system this is a very very
popular in China when I was in China
they just wanted to exchange beach at
accounts with me they don't care about
my email address or my phone number okay
and what's happening in China it's like
what about America well in our facebook
bought whatsapp for 22 billion dollars
and there is a reason with facebook with
1.4 billion people and what's up and six
seven hundred million users they cover
the rest of the world quite well and I
may I just imagined that they just have
to kind of copy we chat and then they
can really dominate the world so that's
why i was saying is that I'm saying
software eats the world social beats the
world so this is where we are at and so
there is a question there are two it's
very very tough questions the first one
is privacy there are lots of people who
think that privacy is dead there is no
more privacy but but we have
intellectual property in education we
have to do commerce we have to
communicate and share finance health and
so forth what does it mean if we don't
have the ability to share data without
having somebody listen to us and if you
don't care about concern about privacy
we you may want to care about a monopoly
because of the network effect we're
getting to a point where all the
communication is owned by a single
company and if that happens only one
company benefits and everybody else
suffers so the question is whether there
will be open competition as a result of
this so in 2008 2007 when the iphone
first came out we thought about it and
we said
look there is a new mobile Internet in
the making and I think it is really you
know we think that is really important
for the universities to have a chance to
build an open system because we know
that the largest companies would like to
lock people into their their proprietary
technologies so we run a proposal to NSF
and we were very happy that we got one
of the first NSF expedition and I have
Jeanette to thank for that and so we got
the we got the funding in 2008 and off
we went and we were studying how to
create a mobile into a programmable open
mobile internet and what I want to talk
about today it has three parts the first
part is I'm going to talk about briefly
about the research side in the research
I mean I'm a hot core systems person but
what I notice is that despite all this
work on distributed systems we ended up
with this most simplistic architecture
which is a centralized system where data
are owned by a single proprietary entity
and I believe that the problem is that a
lot of the systems work was done without
the consideration of HCI so in the in
the years following in the first four or
five years we published papers only in
the HDI conferences and low wide web
conferences as actually as a matter of
fact we couldn't have gotten into
systems conferences because we don't
have data yeah at that time so anyway so
this is really a research project to
combine systems than HCI so that's the
first stage and we are very interested
in really making an impact in the world
so my research group and I started this
company and and we learn a lot about the
go-to-market how do we actually make it
possible for the consumers to use this
technology and this is really very
fundamental technology it actually
changes how the world changes the
experience and by the way it is through
the change of experience that can that
we
and give it that we can get this
technology adopted privacy by itself
does not sell okay so we spend all this
time working on HDI so we because of
this foundation we have seven new
sharing experience that I want to you
know share with you so so in two
thousand and a we got started we spent
four years in each of the first three
years we came up with some really bad
ideas and we learn from that in the
fourth year we finally put it all
together and this is the result it is
actually very very simple but of course
we know that only simple ideas work in
the head so let's see and so on the left
here it's the clothes and centralized
networks that we know and you know we
have all these very very smart phones
very powerful phones but we still
treated them like they are dumb thin
clients okay we have these phones in
order to share we attach these thin
phones with your mothership in this case
Facebook for example and when we want to
share we have to give up our data let
Facebook own it so that Facebook can
share with us according to the rules
that they have and that's very very
limiting for a very powerful device you
know I have my fault you have your
phones we all spend money on this data
plan okay I should be able to take a
picture of you share it with you through
our data plan and we don't need to have
somebody else take the data take take
the ownership of the data you know this
idea that oh it's free and therefore we
should own your data that doesn't make
sense I pay a lot of money for this for
this data plan so instead of doing it
this way we propose a totally very
different architecture and let us have
to have the phones be able to connect
with each other right today I have your
phone number I can call you I don't care
what social network that you joined but
I can call you what we see in the future
is that you have a phone number I should
have my date my app can connect with
your app on your phone and that's it and
why can't we do that it's me
of TCP IP address okay I don't even know
my tcp IP address let alone yours I
cannot connect with you based on our IP
address so what we need is a chatting
protocol it's a messaging protocol that
allows us to use identities that we know
such as your phone number your email
address your facebook account and so why
so that's how we came up with this
concept of a chat system that allows you
to use existing identities it's a group
messaging network that means that if I
want to send a message to three people I
create a group just like I create a
email you know header with three names
and i say i want to send it to these
three people it goes straight to the
messenger the messenger takes a look and
then and then you know everybody has to
kind of register with this messaging
layer and so when it receives a message
it says it goes to these three guys then
it knows which machines or which phones
that the system has to notify then they
notify the system the systems come back
they pick up the message and the message
is this messaging system can delete the
data okay so because the phones are not
necessarily on all it's on the policy
here is that the messaging system was
keep the data for two weeks so so that's
the underlying networking the underlying
messaging system and on top of that we
provide all the apps to have the API
into the system so that this allows you
for example to build a little Scrabble
game between four phones without having
a single server all right because how do
you write a circle game it is this when
I play a game I play our word it's just
a message going to those three phones
there's no need to stand up a server
okay if I don't have a server out there
there's absolutely no way I'm leaking
any private data okay which is a very
different architecture from what we have
today which is all you know every single
time you interact with somebody it has
to go through a server who usually takes
the ownership of the data so so
that's the that's the core and in the
meantime you'd say what does it mean
you're going to delete the data then how
am I supposed to keep my data is like
when I pick up a new phone if I lose our
new phone where's the data so what we do
is that we let every single person to
decide where they want to keep their
data it could be a box or Dropbox or the
SkyDrive or the google drive and if you
are in China maybe you're using the
Baidu cloud and so forth so it allows
every person to choose their own cloud
service and I think this is very
important because you know if you look
at the international scenario right I
mean there is there there is a lot of
reason why come citizen in the foreign
country may not want to keep their data
in an American storage I think that that
is pretty well understood because of the
Snowden and you know the you know
because of because of what happened and
we all know how the how the government
is able to get access to users data
everywhere so what we have Caribbean
really here is a combination of a
chatting system with a lot of api's so
allow everybody to build on top of it
and then it is also distributing this
social data so in other words we take
the social network and turn it inside
out so instead of everybody puts in you
the data into the middle we all decide
where it is and then we're just
distributing the data to the cloud
service of your choice and it all they
all interoperate so technically what we
have created is a distributed semantic
file system okay what does that mean
semantic filesystems means that you can
refer to the data based on who what how
where well as opposed to file names
there are no meaning or full file names
find a mobile device and at the same
time it is distributed because now they
are stored in all the different places
and it's running on top of an open
messaging system that is basically a
content-based addressing network okay
and there are two sets of API there are
the cloud AP ice and
we expose the semantic file system to
native apps to OEM maps to server app
there's also a server app API and we
also create a new kind of app new kind
of API and that is the p2p web app API
that means they can write a little Petey
Petey little web code that kind of runs
only on the phones without having a
server and it's just routed by the
social by the messaging layer so that's
the that's the technology that we have
created so let's talk about the second
part which is category market so what we
have created is this distributed
semantic file system how do you go
market just really we learned a lot in
the last three years so we saw the
research in 2008 and our team started
the company in 2012 and by March 2014 we
have a product it is called the armlet
chat and we launched itself by Southwest
last March and you know last March there
was a lot the the keynotes were a sludge
and Snowden there was a lot of interest
in privacy and we became the most
tweeted app at the launch and we were
also included as part of I Stanford and
what it means is that it i said it's the
official app from stanford and they
points to omelet because the register
really wants to encourage students to
use a social network that does not own
their intellectual property and at the
same time we got a lot of press very
excited about what we're doing because
of the you know we are just breaking the
paradigm so ink magazine has a printed
article on us and they said that it's an
insanely ambitious assault on the entire
facebook model and venturebeat talked
about our pas me they are NSF expedition
and they said this that this stanford
team is reinventing the entire internet
for just ten million dollars so we're
very excited about the launch
and then the next question is how to
remove the masses to you know there are
1.4 billion people on Facebook and
hundreds of millions on WeChat how do we
get to the end users so after spending
some time on it we just rediscovered
that the key here is that there is
interest in open systems I mean it meant
remember the AOL days okay the AOL says
that you know you go through our browser
and this is the links that you're
supposed to visit but eventually that
went away and we have an open Internet
because we all want to go visit the
there are many many companies out there
other than AOL so what we discovered is
that there were a lot of companies who
are interested in a open system and a
lot of it has to do with that they saw
the threat of reach at and so because of
the all the businesses being rolled out
inside we checked there is a there is a
threat of companies like WeChat and
Facebook basically recreating all the
different kind of apps under their
social umbrella the kind of putting you
know they try you know in a in a sense
big they are eating this this world of
apps instead of doing that we offer a
different alternative and that is that
if you take the existing apps that are
out there turn them make them social or
under a common social network under the
same open umbrella then we will be then
then they you know then the companies
can participate and the consumers get a
better experience so all that becomes
kind of like a catalyst it's just a
neutral technology that brings all the
different companies together to create a
social network and so in so even though
we are a little company we actually get
the support of the largest companies so
this is the good news is that many large
partners have joined omelets and if we
have we have to announced partners so
those ones I can share with you
as I mentioned we launched in march two
thousand fourteen and by may 2014 we are
already embedded on every single phone
that a sous built okay so we were
working with them you know a year before
we launched so they actually were a
really great partner they helped us
finish the app a lot of people said to
me is like why are you working with OEM
say slow you down I said they didn't
they actually helped us finish the
product faster so HTS launched last year
in May and while we announced in at CES
this year that they are our partner and
maybe some of you are not familiar with
Huawei and the phone business but they
are actually the number three largest
game makers in the world so we're very
excited about the partnership and we
will be launching very very soon with
Huawei they made 80 million phones last
year okay so we are very excited and I
think we will get too many many more
users and and by the way they didn't
just preload us they actually built
their apps on top of us because we are a
social platform and i will show you an
example of that in them in a little bit
so oh yeah it's a distribution partner
we also have some content partners we
worked with we we are partnering with
many large game companies there's media
and there are also financial
institutions that are that want to work
with us and that we were there we are
partnering with so between all these all
these partners we expect that in the
next couple of years will be we will
have a we will reach over here we will
reach hundreds of millions of users
through our partners stout and oh also
and then our partners they call us the
Switzerland of social okay and what that
means is that we are a neutral company
and I think it has a lot to do is the
fact that the technology is built and in
the university and you know we talked to
every company we are we are not this is
not technology built by any large
companies so they felt like when we say
we are open people believe us and I
think that that is a very important role
that
University researchers can play so they
call us the Switzerland of social so so
that's they that's a short description
of three years of very hard work let's
talk about what this means when you kind
of adopt a when you have an open
messaging system at the bottom and I
want to talk about seven new sharing
experiences all right so number seven
you're going to see a new style of web
apps instead of server client we're
going to see a lot of p2p web apps and
they will be replacing these siloed
experiences because today if I want to
you know any any kind of social
experience that we want we have to go
and recreate a social network but in
this model you don't have to do that
because your groups of friends are on
your phone directly all right so let me
explain this so far I have not shown
anything about the social up about the
user experience but everything is about
the user experience so let's get started
so how do you explain a user experience
I want to show you how we used our phone
okay how we use this messaging system so
this is a real example okay i went to a
Stanford football team Stanford football
game and I'm sitting right behind this
guy in the white shirt and I took a
picture of the field that's the
background and we were doing extremely
well that game and every single time we
get a touchdown this guy sitting in
front of me was a white shirt will take
off his white shirt and chest bump his
friend in front of everybody in the
stadium okay so i figure that it is fair
game so I took a picture of them and I
have a lot of my teammates are working
there they are not enjoying his
pathology so i thought i would share
that experience with them so I I took a
picture and share it with in this on the
chat and
so soon after that within the couple of
minutes my one of my former students and
co-founder yeah yeah Ian thought that
these two guys were not nude enough so
they took a little apt called notifier
and then he they added some more flesh
tone to the spectra and you know and we
had a good luck and then another another
kid got up and they say oh I have
another idea about what to do with this
picture and they just took the picture
quickly edit it with some of those you
know there's this small apps on the
phone and add a little bit of comment
and share it back out with our team and
and I thought that was pretty funny and
look at how many likes that Ben got so
the whole point here is like we are
actually collaborating we are not just
putting up a picture for people just see
you can take this picture click click it
do something with it and share back and
this is something that you will never
see on an email system and/or on a
Facebook system and at that point I
decided that they really like this
experience so I just wanted to show them
what it means and we just took a little
chip and actually showed them what is
happening in the stadium at Stanford and
the reason why we were able to do this
is that in this messaging app there is a
drawer that is a plus sign and when you
cur and you click on it you see oh I got
many many likes and then there is a
drawer of these apps and it is an open
API anybody can write apps and stick it
into this drawer just like you know you
have a browser used to be able to visit
many many many different web pages
without having to download an app every
single time so this is an open API and
everybody gettin right absent in this
format so for example one of the kids
wrote an app on this call and emotions
and instead of using canned stickers you
can click you can you you know here in a
few days he wrote a little app where he
actually can't express himself in this
didn't these gifs and now whenever he
talks he can just pick and pick these
pick these these little clips of himself
to
talk to his friends okay so it is a
fully extendable extensible system it is
very very easy to do give you an example
how many people have played 2048 okay
it's a very simple little open-source
soft piece of software and one of my non
programming employee says that she wants
to share the score she really likes
escape so we taught her how to turn this
little app into a social app you add
about 13 lines of tiny little lines over
there and now you're able to take the
score and off the game and then share
with your friends and challenge your
friends okay why it's because all the
work in creating groups and sharing and
messaging are done and we exposed it and
let everybody else kind of just write a
little code and take advantage of it so
just another example here Rishabh Jain
is at that time he was a sophomore and
he thought that it would be cool if you
take a picture and show it for a few
seconds and delete the picture have you
heard of that before okay that's kind of
like what snapchat does for you but
instead of building a company that
eventually that is currently what 15
billion 20 billion I don't I'm losing
track so he built a little app that
allows you to share the pictures in a
few seconds and he was able to do it
like in two days okay because it's not
difficult to make a picture disappear
but the concept here is that you don't
have to recreate a social network every
single time you want to experiment with
a new social interaction by the way I'm
not saying that this will this is going
to take off all right I mean everybody
is already using snapchat for what
snapchat can do very well but you know
this is just an illustration because
there are many many more high school
students out there that can come up with
new experiences that they can write and
extend this browser with now that is
maybe you know you I don't know how many
people here
chat how many people here you snapchat
not that many how many people here use
git git repository alright so here is an
app that you might be interested in so
what does app does is that it uses the
server API so that when whenever you
commit something to the repository the
comment is sent to the group in real
time ok so we call this get chat and
this app was very easy to build it was
like a two days effort because we have
the server API and by the way this is a
function that you can pay for I think
that there is a company out there and
you pay something like seven dollars per
programmer every month in order to get
this functionality but in this case it
is all free ok anybody can connect their
git repository to this chat and every
time somebody checks in you get a
real-time notification what does that do
to a group what it does is that it got
our group to write a lot more comments
ok because now you know typically you
write comments and nobody reads them
because you just check out and in who
sees those comments but now it is
distributed in real time so what it
means is that if some some engineer you
know worked really hard and checked in
some but fakes in the middle of the
night the next morning everybody saw the
bug fix and they would congratulate
those this guy and thank him and stuff
like that so what we have done now is to
create a soap you know is to turn code
coding into a very social experience and
it has done wonders for the group
because we kind of acknowledge each
other and we help each other and it is a
really interesting experience but this
is a tiny little app that we just throw
in and it works all right so in other
words what we see here is that with
these PTP web apps it will replace many
many companies like evite you don't need
to have a company just to help you with
invitations or doodle or even wetbacks
because it is very easy to share within
a group and now
the best part is that you form one group
and now you can use all the different
apps without setting up a social network
every single time so that's number 76 to
go all right what is number six the
number six is that you can do dynamic
data exchange for mobile groups very
very easily so how do you people have a
phone with you you can actually
participate in my life demo okay so i
have created oh actually i have already
got some people joining this chat i have
created a chat if you have omelet you
can go to this page where you see nearby
chats and you will notice that i have
started a chat called the microsoft
faculty summit you can all join and then
we can cut we can connect right now we
can talk right now let me take a picture
of you guys
all right I just shared it with
everybody who has who has omelet okay if
you join this chat so so I tried it at a
another conference I gave a keynote at
the Tizen developer conference and this
is what happened I was I took a picture
just like that with the people in the
audience on stage and then I said I also
have my ties and watch so I took so I
told them I'm going to use my watch to
take a picture of them using the watch
so that picture over there is with my
phone the picture down there is my with
my watch but as I was doing that the
audience were sharing pictures of me in
real time okay so there is somebody in
the audience it took a picture of me to
getting a picture of them and that one
in the top right corner is kind of
interesting what is that what is it it's
a picture that was a mirror image
picture who took that picture it's a
person backstage ok so somebody
backstage actually took a picture of me
taking a picture of the people in the
front and we all share in real time so
this is very easy to do and you know
it's just a little tool that we have it
it's open to anybody you can use it for
anything like at a conference or at a
nightclub ok so we when we launched
itself by Southwest Gabriel and Justin
they were one of the top DJs in America
they used armlet in there and their
nightclub so they are took they took
pictures of the audience the audience of
pictures of them at the same time they
were telling the audience what songs
they are playing and they were telling
them what songs they want to hear the
you know you can imagine at this club it
was very very noisy and even the person
next to you you cannot really talk to
them so you can just message with each
other but the cool things are cool thing
about this is that it allows people to
join up we interact at the conference or
outside or after the conference and
there is nothing more to it you don't
become my facebook friends just because
we happen to be at a nightclub together
okay so so the point really here is that
if you look at these two scenarios what
we are used to is that there will be an
app for conference or web for wedding
and a web for the night clubs and stuff
like that but there is no need for that
you can use it for anything and the best
part here is that this is a piece of the
data being exchanged stay with the group
there is no company owning the data
being exchanged so that's number six
what is number five number five is that
we are we we will be seeing these
natively social phones so for example
this is the social gallery that and that
ace use made our first partner okay so
we have used to having galleries of all
the pictures that you take that we take
individually or we can go to a wedding
and then we took we put pictures up but
it is usually my pictures of the wedding
and you took the pictures you take of
the same wedding but what we are able to
do here is to create a collaborative
photo album in real time and share using
your Android using your gallery so let
me walk you through that so the first
panel over there shows you the view of
the gallery it says these are all the
collaborative photo albums that means
that all the pictures taken come from
your friends and yourself it is not only
pictures that you take so we did that at
a wedding this was Ben's wedding and we
click and then if you click on the photo
album you see that there is a front page
and then there are all these people
participating if I click on the person
then you see that I can chat with this
person directly and when I'm done
chatting I return to the gallery and the
gallery all the pictures have social
features on it it has hearts on these
pictures and if you click into it you
know who other people liking the bride's
picture and I can like the picture right
on the spot right with the pictures
inside the gallery I don't have to go
join a social network so that we can
like each other's pictures okay so that
is in your guy
and this group that you have in this
gallery can be used with any app on the
phone if I write a little game I want to
tap into this group I just make an API
call and I was able to do this so this
app was created by ASUS they did not
write a single line of server code or
messaging code they just call our API on
the phone and the group's belong to the
phone they never know what groups you
have okay so what oh I mentioned that we
have a semantic a mantic filesystem it
just it's just a diagram to show how you
can locate pictures by just following
the information of the semantic links so
that's number five let's move on number
four is that we're going to see a lot
more vertical social networks so for
example Facebook started out as a
vertical social network for Harvard to
connect with each other but soon after
that it becomes generic and what we saw
is that there are a lot of
special-purpose single the single
purpose social networks and of course
Facebook has to pick them up because you
know people are moving away from you
know our interacting outside of the
generic networks and then there are the
gentle and then then we saw and what's
up and we chat these are the general
purpose group of communications but uber
is an example of a very very vertical
social network that connects drivers and
riders together and what we imagine in
the future is that there will be many
many more networks they are relatively
easy to build because now we have these
platforms for creating social networks
for example LX you want students in
America to be able to work with students
in China and sharing documents and
communicating on their projects but
today of course Facebook and Google are
not inside China and we're not really
able to do some of these most to use
some of these most common tools so what
we see here is the rise of more vertical
social networks with the help of these
open social platforms that's number four
number three we're see going to see a
lot of use of the messenger the chats
for businesses
so here's just some examples so for
example a bank may be talking to you and
say I see that you are making a charge
in Japan are you there and instead of
using the very insecure SMS or email
they can use the system because all the
endpoints are validated I'm happy to
respond because I know that that is bank
of america on the other side they can
also put in apps that will help you with
the travel such as you know they know
which flight you are on so when you lose
your when you miss your flight you don't
have to stand in line there will be
these apps on the phone and then you
just collect it they already know what
your bags look like and so forth you
don't have to stand you know they know
the context of the conversation so
that's number three all right what is
number two number two is the distribute
is the Internet of Things john chambers
said that the Internet of Things is at
19 trillion dollar market do you believe
it yeah well I do Google spent 3.2
billion on just a thermostat company and
that's not that far I mean you know to
get to the the trillion-dollar market
why did they spend so much money on the
thermostat company it's cuz of the data
okay and when that happens there are a
lot of questions when then social times
ask who will be the Google of the
Internet of Things who do you think it
is do you really want to have a Google
of the Internet of Things google
searches the whole world so that you can
now tap into it and find out everything
do you really want to have a Google of
the Internet of Things so they can tap
into everybody's bedroom video cameras
and so forth is that really where we are
heading possible okay so for example
obviously your security camera should
notice who's in the house or who's not
in the house and to turn down the heat
accordingly and so these devices have to
talk to each other if the only thing we
know how to build is data centers where
all the data
communicate then we might get into a
situation again where there is a
winner-takes-all situation where all the
different devices are connected to the
same data center so the picture that I
showed you where we have a distribute at
the open messaging for distributed thing
distributed phones can be applied to the
Internet of Things where things can be
connected so there you just create these
little networks and there is no need for
anybody to be in the middle of all the
communications and what we see here is
that the messaging layer can you know
when it comes to internet of things you
don't have to run all the same apps you
don't have to run all the games and so
forth there is no reason to stick to a
you know one or two operating systems
but it is very important that they all
interact with each other it's a little
bit like html5 right the server and
client they all interact with each other
so what we are proposing here is that if
there we can standardize on an open
messaging network then it didn't run
across all the different operating
systems and then one way for you to
enter connect them with writing these
p2p web apps it is very very lightweight
and now you really see the ability for
many many devices to interact with each
other so that is my number two to
distribute it Internet of Things okay
you're ready for number one so what we
see here is like if we succeed with this
vision that means that a lot of things
will be connected via this distributed
network and we will what we really
believe in is that all this traffic
would be worked all the way down to the
heart where equipment may be using the
software-defined networks that my
colleague developed in the same
programmable open mobile internet
expedition funded by NSF and and you
know that would be a new basis that
supports mobile devices and the Internet
of Things so let me conclude here it is
like we are at the we are still at the
early stage of a new computer generation
we have seen the swing from mainframes
to pcs
you know back to the cloud and with
mobile devices the only scalable thing
to do really is to is to have
distribution and it is really the
beginning of what I what people call a
privacy economy and and I believe it
will be supported by distributed
computing there's a lot of research
topics here and I hope that the research
heroes can can't jump in and pitch in
and you know download armlet and talk to
me talk to everybody using an open
messaging system well thank you for your
attention and I don't know how much time
you have time for some questions so
raise your hand and they'll come race to
you with the microphone
number two gets to go first yeah hi my
question is how would an open
programming programmable network like
omelette make money monetization model
we discovered that is possible the
reason is that there are a lot of
companies that want to make more money
by adopting social features and we help
them with the social features and they
are willing they are happy to share some
of that revenues with us and so we are a
friend rather than their enemy and
because we allow all the companies to
retain their user experience they're
happy to pull together to greatness
network but they do need a lot of help
and we provide that and that's how we
can make money especially if you know
everybody is on top of an open system we
will have a lot of customers what's the
power cost of a fully distributed shared
say gallery and a wedding where 300
people are all sharing images off their
phones to each other directly versus
getting them out of the clouds office
Marcela question I just want to make
sure you I mean I don't know that
explain it properly but when we sit when
we send a message to 300 people we said
one message to the server there is a
server and then it is then distributed
to all the other phones this is very
important because some of the times the
phones are not online and it has to be
held to kenny manny University of
Edinburgh I when I just went and tried
to install the app it had a phenomenal
number of permissions it wanted an
impressive number actually I haven't
seen that many for quite very many apps
and so do some privacy research there
was immediate gut reaction of OD god I
don't want this on my phone I'm
wondering how you've done a lot of work
with the user experience on this how
much are you seeing in an additional
adoption problem from some of these
initial from
requests and the amount of potential
invasiveness to create an app of this
type which is privacy sensitive very
good question so I talked to some
Facebook people and they said that they
did an experiment where they change the
number of permissions and it has no
effect on how whether people will
download the gap or not so that's for
the layman okay but for you will I would
suggest is that you look at our Terms of
Service we have now gotten to a point
where we think that as long as you have
access to my camera or whatever
everything belongs to them and that's
why we are very sensitive or the privacy
oriented people very sensitive to the
permissions but if you look at our Terms
of Service it doesn't give me any right
to do anything with it and this is the
something that I'm very you know sad
about that we have kind of forgot about
the terms of service we don't you know
Facebook and put in a pretty nasty Terms
of Service and think of all the users
anyway so we kind of have to educate the
people that it is really what contract
what contract I have with you and by us
having all these permissions this allow
us to then manage the devices and when
you have apps that use us whether they
have the permission or not you know that
is something we can control and then we
also have to you know we kind of have to
ask the user if they grant those
permissions to the people that use us
okay so we kind of we're kind of like a
part of the social operating system and
that is the reason why we have to have
so many permissions three hello I'm
wondering what happens if you have a
data plan and you share a picture with
100 people so there is no server between
my picture is going to be access it 100
times using my data we do have servers
okay it is just that business policy
that stops us from tick owning your data
so you already sent one message to the
server and the server notifies all these
phones and when they come in you know
ask for the data then we give it to them
so for how long is this data stored in
cheers
it's nice because the system we have
works for multiple devices so some
people may have a tablet and they don't
turn it on all the time and and they
came from the same you know they're able
to keep all their devices synced up we
drop the data after two weeks but if you
hooked up a back up and a cloud service
with it then the data will be streaming
out of your own cloud service too let's
be hi Lily Chang this is awesome I just
love the experimentation so thanks for
showing it if you guys haven't tried it
out there's a bunch of people i don't
know in there it's really fun and if
you're sitting nearby we've been taking
pictures of you and drawing mustaches on
you but one question that i have is
we've been looking a lot at group
communication so right now we have a
group chat how is the use of group chat
different and do you think the storage
concerns are different for groups
because sometimes groups might want to
access that shared information over time
or persist that group so I'm just
wondering about how you persist how you
let users especially in groups persons
to information so we have given a lot of
thoughts to that and a messaging system
typically is for close friends and this
is also an area that Facebook didn't do
very well on and that's the focus but
there are also opportunities ins why
people may have more open group
discussions so for example if I have a
group at the stadium okay many people
may be participating and at that point
you will change how how how you want to
support that I kind of talked about this
concept of a vertical social network so
for specific apps where you expect a lot
of expect a public audience then you
will take the primitives that we have
and then you throw a server at it and
then you may not have the same policies
about the delivery of messages and so
forth so it is something that that is
also available and it is complementary
to
what we are talking about here so we can
talk more offline about this one last
question number four yes no so so for
example our OEM has all the permissions
our OEM partners well they have all the
permissions but for everybody else the
basic thing that we do is the single
origin policy all right you can only
look at the data that you generate and
then on top of that if you are accessing
sensors and so forth and we kind of we
need to kind of we need to get at get
the permission from the individuals so
think a little bit like the browser
today and the browser is a way for you
to end force some some amount of
security and privacy and this is
basically the same thing here so we are
very much like you know the browser we
think of it as the web OS because now it
sits across all the different operating
systems and in the same way we're kind
of like the social OS that we you know
whatever you really want to do is to be
on every single device like a browser is
on every single device these days all
right I think we have one more in the
back
that's working yeah so a lot of what you
talked about was predicated on the fact
that it's distributed but you're going
to a server so isn't it like a
regardless of how long it's in the
server it's on a server that's
potentially on US soil so all of your
privacy concerns all of your trust is
really just now being delegated from
Facebook to your organization and it's
not really decentralized first of all
the most important difference is that
Facebook has the entire history of all
the years that you have spent on
facebook starting from the day you're
born in some cases okay in our case we
are only keeping the data for two weeks
and we actually have a distributed
protocol we have a server inside China
and if all the information is between
people in China then it never leaves the
Chinese soil okay so so we believe that
you have to have a server because these
are mobile devices they are on and off
so think of it as we really have tried
to put in whatever you know the minimum
amount of access so that we can make
this work so that we can give people are
you a good user experience and the most
important thing is look at our Terms of
Service it is different from the terms
of service from from google and from
facebook all right thank you thank you
just can I say one more thing like I
know that there are a lot of people from
different countries it is you know I
think it is great if we can have you
guys tried it out hey take it back home
build apps or experiment and do research
on top of it and that would be great
because most social networks are started
by the 15 year old kids and now you know
maybe we can start one among the
computer scientists who actually
understand the issues of centralized
social networks thank you thank you hope
to see on omelet
each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
you